The way the GPU, usually solves the visibility problem, is by using what is
called a Z buffer or if you have British meanings, it is pronounced zed buffer.
The artist Lennart Anderson once said, landscape painting is really just a box
of air with little marks in it telling you how far back in that air things are,
it's not the[UNKNOWN] of quotes, but this is a pretty good description of the Z
buffer algorithm. The Z in the Z buffer stands for distance from the camera.
Buffer is just another word for a data array like an image. So, for the image,
in addition to storing a color at each pixel we also store a distance which is
called the z-depth. The z-depth is often considered as a floating point number
that ranges from 0, meaning close to the eye to 1, meaning the maximum distance
from the eye. The z-buffer is initially cleared by filling O with 1s.